okay four people joining this livestream
we are looking at a long-awaited
function categorical distribution um and
maybe it is gonna send me a notebook
here or am I just going to start just
send it now
you
okay
cool all right
input type scale scaler make me a number
no yeah so it can be both univariate and
multivariate so here use the same
terminology as I use for every machine
learning function so you should do a
multivariate one it's gonna put like
vector and the size of the vector okay
so okay so here I'm gonna say random
variate and fine it will do the obvious
thing I say the PDF and a discrete
distribution so if I have like a Poisson
distribution you're saying am i confused
here if I have a Poisson distribution is
there a default Poisson distribution
then if I say PDF of that of X
I see okay fair enough um if I say um
PDF of CD of X you can't do anything
yeah not leave them yeah yeah at least
it doesn't evaluate which is a design
decision that I made I think is the
right one
so because it's categorical distribution
it can be basically anything yes
including symbol including X like you
could put ABC X so or it could be or it
could also be a picture of a dog or
something exactly it could be anything
except list or I think Association is
also forbidden because it will mess up
with with a passing of is there one
element for example in PDF for is a two
element in PDF so least least a
forbidden but but it's like many more
constraint before I added that if you
evaluate to anything else that what in
the domain it would be zero for the PDF
but that was kind of a problem for using
you know PDF for example of oh well I
think it's a problem because the
isomorphism testing is not guaranteed
right it's not obvious that you can tell
that they're the same I mean that then
you're doing then you're making this
essentially a pattern matching function
which is not clear it should be yeah so
so now everything that is out of domain
it's unevaluated
for PDF and I think that server I think
it makes sense it's the same for normal
distribution I mean if I define on you
I'm I'm more concerned about your
forbidding lists as elements in the
categorical distribution
oh this I think we cannot escape it huh
it's like a kind of worm is Donna
accepting that like right PDF can have
one element to element and you see it
here to the FFL of least a V I so juicer
and this this is like um okay
that's cool is that similar what we get
for another like if I say information of
that Poisson distribution
I think not at the moment is that
nothing is that is a good idea I mean
Roger go sure what do you think is not
planned at this time
okay do you think it's a bad idea for
categorical distribution um No
okay
but that'sthat's like a little tail on a
giant dog so it's a huge difference what
do you mean it's one out of hundreds of
distributions I'm well aware
and it's little special
fair enough so let me see what happens
if I say
so if I say top probabilities are those
properties
so then argument of information
which are analogous to what you get out
from machine learning functions is that
correct
which of these can you get out from a
machine learning function all these
properties I think you learn
distribution you can get the entropy I
forgot if I read it or not okay so but
the interoperability of categorical
distribution and results from machine
learning what is the in other words you
got a picture yeah yeah so I didn't put
that yet
but it's true the classifier function
you could return either probabilities
and we should add distribution in the
same way
yes predict yeah same was pretty tall
function returns a distribution now
classify will be able to return
distribution when does predict a
function return distribution when you
ask for distribution in what what kind
of this property turn most of the time a
normal distribution in the case of
building yeah it's a just random real
you know can come 100 and then I say
predict all I want to say I just say put
this then you have to put label so you
could do an arrow and put the same on am
real if you want I know why it's typing
not I got my typing but anyway why is it
taking so long
wow I noticed some slowdown in this
prototype build I don't know maybe it's
front-end I don't know what's going on
okay
it should be supervised listening okay
so now how do I get the distribution I
said that and no there's no distribution
so you need to give it a value let's say
predict what went for the value 5 no and
then you would come a distribution 5
comma
like this it is the oh that's very cool
okay so you should be able to do the
same thing with classify exactly I have
to where it's question on livestream
from Mohammed will rare a probability
optimized in 12.1 for performance will
what rare a probability depends
for what
I wonder I wonder for which distribution
the user won't want that to be faster
but but we won't change anything for
this version so I mean I guess the short
answer is no he won't be optimized but
I'm curious about optimize for what
right now what is module that can answer
um okay so now this is the bivariate
categorical distribution this one yep
and it can be here as many viable
okay I'm sorry this is a triviality but
do we usually uppercase the right hand
sides of these things do you know in
machine learning I doing other things
maybe not rate we do hopefully we do
oh that's nice you've got the table
there I hope you do something sensible
if that gets out of hand
yes I do actually if you want you can
scroll down the okay how do I get a
table out of this how would I get that
table out information information for
the distribution and then probability
table actually by the way I don't forget
to get a daughter completely true okay
what is that creature is that which
actually is have a different you don't
know the change of style there is out of
frame now oh those are many changes this
is the new Chris Carlson better faster
greatly improved dataset that's all the
kinds of interesting things in it okay
fair enough and these have been
normalized so if I give it yeah okay
what is your go ahead okay I wonder how
it looks this new data set on this when
you have many variables don't be nice to
look at I didn't check yet you should
check it it's a little bit better but if
you don't like some aspect of it
complain to Chris okay marginal
distribution is that something we've had
before yes yes and that's that is
marginal distribution with respect to
what in a vector is that correct yeah
first way I've also done Rob all you can
do at least as well okay
[Music]
okay actually let me let me go ahead and
um I'll see here how do I do well here
let me just do this if I do a
categorical distribution just for the
hell of it just just to be more
stressful for it and I do here
you
so I I there's no there's no
he's a 10 very--it exactly and each of
them has 10 it's gonna be a lot of a lot
of things so actually you won't be able
to filled up with weights so it has to
be sparse right now it's and by then
it's 10 to the 10 weights that you have
to specify now here I'm just specifying
6 plates indeed because it's 3 times 2
right first so now it's 10 to the 10
weights so you can do its parsing or why
is it 10 to the 10 weights as opposed to
just a hundred weights because the
domain you're specifying so first
argument is a domain you have 10
variables each of them of 10 possible
values that's what you're specifying
with the first argument wait a second
but here I'm saying the possible values
are ad c e whatever this oh I see I see
what you're saying actually they don't
that's why you say times they're
actually it's going to be less because
they're going to be some some duplicate
they're going to be ignored when you run
them integer right sometimes gonna be
the same thing so it's not really well
we don't really know what the domain
will be so it's actually it's gonna be
even impossible to specify the weights
because we don't know what the domain
actually is is it 1 2 3 is it 1 5 7 is
it what I mean
all right okay you're convincing me I'll
try a slightly smaller example so here
what happens is there a default for the
second argument or not yes it's gonna be
uniform distribution so in that case you
add a little bit of actually bit of
duplication
that's why wisely dimensions three times
two times three times three
Oh because it's yeah yeah so I made it
you know I mean it's it's a choice we
couldn't have a message but one is
duplicate I kind of ignored you just
take that as the wait wait this is just
a domain this is just a domain you're
defining here so the weights by default
it's one for every possibility so what
if I wanted to make a categorical
distribution what if I know for each of
these things here okay I know the
probability of each of those combined
things how do I make a categorical
distribution where let's say I've got
this and I want to thread and you know
into this um ah you get what I'm saying
you know you can do that just do that
and okay to go through it and it's gonna
work okay hold on let me just do this
I'm real except there were gonna be
duplicate again but I guess that should
be fine I wonder if I did it duplicate
not
assume so okay so now I say categorical
distribution of that right yeah yeah it
should work and yeah I guess you also
ignore duplicate I wonder which one it
took in the end this is gonna work so
this is one so if you want to go over
the way to create the critical
distribution
it's like few section down on the
creation section okay okay okay fine
I'll let me get on with this oh my gosh
okay I know not not all of them I was
you know discussing some is just showing
this is we already talked about yeah
he's already talked about there so now
probably an expectation this is the one
I'm not sure gonna work on yours but
maybe try so it's just to show to my
shrah scale just to show what you can do
is he has one thing what is it laughter
what is that at etienne how far did you
get with mixed distributions because of
probability expectation take you know
lots of distributions you gave lots of
variables both coins yeah so I was
surprised cause yet fried with any
distribution and it was apparently
working I must say that I I mean I was
surprised if it was always working I'm
sure we can break it in some way so that
would be something to to work on I must
say that we have the same I mean I
managed to broke it also with with a
quantity distribution so kind of my
golden stand-down in developing this was
everything that works with quantity
distribution I have to make it work as
well and and for what was not working
coming you should be sure and I was like
okay maybe it's a bit harder so I
postponed that to later was kind of
understand something so when you say
categorical distribution so for example
we want to use this I think we already
hooked it up for the quantum stuff where
you know it's saying problems if you
spin up and spin down right
it's a little weird to me that the
category I mean this is the right word
for it is that right categorical
distribution that's really yeah yeah
okay okay fine so what we're not worried
by the fact that it will come out spend
spend plus a half spend minus a half
that's even though those are numbers
okay what does this mean here the
problem is that x equals a when x and y
oh I see what you're saying yeah I get
it
nice beautiful actually so if I were to
do this I mean I was will actually work
on my I'm version but but um so if I
would say probability that X y equals a
for example and this is distributed
according to the thing that I'm up here
what do you know very cool so this would
be the same as a PDF actually in that
case in that very case right I
understand but when it when it's a
probability that that X equal oh yeah he
should some clear you could look at a
table and he should sum everything that
is in the in the row of executing all
right very nice very nice then there's
probably
actually how we will implement it
alternating the plane probably entropy
and I wanted to discuss something okay
that's how you can compute entropy with
expectation then you have an expectation
we put you know multicolored methods and
there was one design discussion about
documenting already or not compute
instant eruption I saw would return a
round object that's for which for
entropy or for these other things all
the N Things an expectation and
probability can that be done so it's
darn with don't know if it can be done
with all the methods any method that I
did yes I cannot doubt it does that
seemed to me the uncertainty for an
expectation oh wait a minute that that
that assumes that you use a Monte Carlo
method in that case yeah if you don't
use a Monte Carlo method for there is
uncertainty there you know expectations
are certain there's nothing uncertain
about expectations n expectation yeah
enik there's nothing uncertain about n
ik what does it mean if Amin Amin okay
so we right now we have mean around
which is a with uncertainty mean right
yeah but what I'm saying is expectation
an imitation or deterministic
there's nothing uncertain about them I'm
not disagreeing with that I want to
understand a mean is an expectation of X
right in the distribution correct yes
okay so what we have done in the case of
mean is we say there is another function
okay mean around which gives the mean
together with its uncertainty correct
but that's that's the data that's that's
which when you use estimation okay so if
you just use the descriptive statistics
function mean yes then you're going to
use an estimator do to get the mean but
your point is on the
distribution it is what it is it's what
it is it's deterministic however there
is an uncertainty because he uses a
Monte Carlo method I understand that
this method so that's that's it should
be related to that method and not
globally for a second yeah go ahead
I mean I think it could be for everyone
and in that case for example take the
second line of oven entropy like any
expectation one could computer stantly
true and and what I do in that case
because it's actually an exact method so
I don't return stats equal in certainty
I just returns a numeric and certainty
of of the of the float and she's
diffused what do you mean in American
sir do you mean as in a sim world
significance arithmetic yes you can say
it is all arithmetic what you can try it
if you evaluate basically okay just try
it okay evaluate the catechol
distribution first yeah this one you can
copy paste and you put in the end
expectation the second one exactly and
in the neck they just know the line that
exactly is one I don't know why it stays
blue oh that's wrong that's wrong that's
wrong that's because you have an older
thing so basically what it does that it
returned 10 minus 10 to the power of
minus accuracy of the number okay that's
crazy I mean we could do that throughout
the system but I think that that's that
is the least I mean that's that's not
our problem here exactly uncertainty we
have on this number right I understand
that I understand that but but
throughout the system we could say that
every number we instead of returning you
know just a number with a finite number
of digits we could say it's that number
of digits plus minus the uncertainty but
we're not doing that I mean it will be
an amusing thing to do but we're not
doing it
I mean I'm sure if we say around and
then we say n of 4.5 or something
doesn't do that as a way of getting it
to do that isn't there well let's say
maybe if you don't use machine machine
precision
I thought it did that I'm confused here
why it's not doing that maybe it hmm oh
oh I know what the problem is
there we go right but normally we
absolutely do not do that I mean I mean
that that wouldn't be a by default right
this like opt-in she said understand she
it would return a round object basically
okay fine but I I think okay listen this
case with Monte Carlo makes some sense
to me because it's actually a big effect
in this case here the chance that you
managed to get this distribution so
accurate
the limited by the machine precision is
just never gonna happen right whereas
this one where you do some what a call
oh you know that could absolutely happen
although arguably it will be more
consistent in the system to just set the
precision of a number to be appropriate
to the Medeco low accuracy but I don't
know what we're doing like if we if we
evaluate and integrate with Monte Carlo
we're not doing the same kind of thing
there no I mean we could but we haven't
it's an interesting idea
let's but I mean each one of these you
know you do a little twiddle on one
corner of the system and then are you
trying to pivot the rest of the system
which is probably five man years of work
is it worth it yeah I agree
so I think I think the answer is
probably not unless there's a special
reason to have you know that you know
Etienne has returned from the machine
learning stuff and hopefully in the
future from statistical you know
inference stuff we will get you know
uncertainty Etienne has already done
that for a bunch of machine learning
functions and he's trying to expand it
here and maybe think the regression
stuff which is very similar to machine
learning
or already doing that and when we come
back to it it can be sort of a new
iteration of that that was pioneering
when we introduced that in version 6
well wait wait the regression ref is
returning around numbers now is that
true now it returns a bunch of
indicators of the uncertainty of your
predictions of your data but it's
packaged up those were written for
version 6 and they haven't been touched
since right okay now we have a bunch of
new idioms so when we return to it those
new idioms can be applied and we that
will be very nice ok very high so
regression and machine learning is very
similar because it's basically trying to
give a function it's just you know and a
function with with various notions of
uncertainty attached to it I think fits
of the first place where we really want
to see around come up just basic
functions like fit which is regression I
understand that I'm just saying the
sooner we can do that the better
um by the way these are front already
exist right
computers to entities that figure
it is documented before forecast for
measurement and so on yes so it's not
like we're introducing it it shouldn't
be documented for an expectation okay
absolutely not
okay let's talk about the details of the
Montecarlo finger mat let's look here
and sure we have some question on this
live stream surface saying this is
really interesting function I would say
thank you good I should um Mohammed is
asked you'd be nice to have a function
find joint distribution that given any
marginal distribution say distribution
of X associate with random variable X to
find another angle Y not fully but only
conditionally Y given X is distributed
like that now since these popular
distribution is somewhat like that
that's a way to build
to build them from marginal
distributions because the Joint
Distribution XY don't completely
understand this like it could be a
product distribution right that's the
simplest way to do but I think that's
way to make it maybe with some prior
over I don't know a smooth no
distribution I don't know you could do
something a bit smarter that is more
likely to be actual joint distribution
from which this marginal have been
generated sure but one thing that exists
in the system today is copula which is
which is a lot more sophisticated in
product distribution
okay so that's I mean the basic point is
what Joint Distribution would give a
marginal distribution that is
such-and-such is that correct yeah
there's infinitely many obviously but
but this is like I mean it's like a
smooth interpolation of in the space of
distributions to give you the best the
most likely somehow with respect to a
measure on the space of distributions
it's the most likely distribution that
right you would like to figure out I
don't know you were trying to read it
out I didn't understand what you were
saying um you have some partial
definition you have some marginal
information and you want to
you want to get you know possible
multivariate distributions exactly right
you could change the documentation of
copula I didn't know it so so so just
unless you have some other objective or
goal for how to pick between them then
copular distributions already give you
an infinite number of such multivariate
distributions that has the same
marginals that you gave okay with kernel
distribution curve marginal distribution
so I say
you
what's the first argument to this
colonel this about is a fixed list of
common kernels which somewhat relate
like what's the dependence between them
and clearly the product is what you know
as a product distribution when the
marginals are independent okay oh I see
so this is saying by maximal it means
the variable you get out this is a
univariate distribution that you're
getting out is that right worthy where
the output is the maximum of the outputs
of any of the variables from any of
these specific distributions oh you get
multivariate distribution out you get
them I'm confused then what is the
maximal mean it's just a name of it nice
number what does it do just define there
right maximum XML says
so those those distributions u1 u2 and
so on mm-hmm
and those are basically 0-1
distributions and this says this is the
kernel that glues all these and and
different distributions together and the
way that they glue them together is by
the CDF value which is something that
goes from zero to one okay okay so you
have your two couple that that the CDF
and at you so I'm saying the values of
the CDF is 0 to 1 from the user is 0 to
1 and that gives you those functions of
the use that how that dependence among
them looks
okay okay I get it I get it but another
question here is about fine distribution
and it's fine distribution gonna handle
categorical distribution probably not
given the time we have to do these do
because categorical distribution called
on data gives you a distribution so it
kind of finds the distribution so I mean
I don't the fine distribution once works
in finding the parameters for the
parametric models so right but if you
give a function if you say find
distribution if I've given a bunch of a
B's and C's right sure did sure we can
we can that's what categorical
distribution does in its design
right so it's rather this was data goes
currently can recall is only you specify
every weight right and probability by
this would be this was a fine
distribution of that yeah and it should
give a categorical distribution it
should it should we should make it
happen for this yeah maybe a mere I mean
I can take so but if you know like at
the cortical distribution to this data
set to this a C's B's it's gonna give
you categorical distribution of weights
this how to collect one actually know
although an arguably we should just do
it with the weights in other words this
thing about taking the domain and
ignoring how many copies there are of
each thing why do that you're losing
information why not aggregate them and
use the that is the weights that's
that's only for the univariate case in
the middle area is completely different
why because you have a list and it's I
say because the product they're gonna be
some yeah they're going to be some
ambiguity why it's just a product
distribution right so I mean you take
the things in the first list there and
that represents you know your
probabilities there you take things and
second list
it is perfectly reasonable as a product
distribution okay and then put a
distribution of this thing yes yes yes
yes okay that makes sense or you can
have weights on there on a 2d space of
probabilities so I mean what's the
difference you you just have
probabilities no the fact is that the
way categorical distribution is
specified here it is its domain as a
direct product of you know as a product
space here right okay
whereas in fine distribution what I
might have is a bunch of you know a CDE
etc etcetera etcetera pairs just a big
list two pairs it's it's you know it's a
different thing what you're saying you
want to say that you may have you know
data a missing pair which would be
specified directly for the domain yes
and that's that that's that's that's a
valid point actually I wasn't the point
I thought I was making but that sounds
true too
I mean we have estimated distribution
that we should well that's what I was
going to because I was thinking you know
if if we need to add the hook for the
estimated distribution and in light of
this discussion it seems that that
probably that's what you want to do if
you want you have the specification with
a full domain and then have the data
that may not really have all the points
from the domain then you need some other
function yeah I'm just thinking that
estimated distribution would estimate
the weights presumably yes but you give
the categories yes you need to give the
you'll need to provide categorical
distribution with the specified domain
but I'm in might give the unspecified
weights I think that's how I see this
working actually we can talk about that
now if you want next even it's on the
bottom the bottom of the other thing
estimated distribution so nothing is
implemented there one one way to be to
do the exact same thing
other you know symbolic distribution
like you could ABC as weights I was
since the number of wait can get really
big get recall distribution I was
wondering if there's one way that we
could you know I don't know that I mean
if what you do I understand the point so
I don't think one should mess with the
structure of estimated distribution I
think you should leave that with a
limited set of symbolic parameters that
it is essentially fitting but I think
your point is that could be automatic
instead of ABC I don't know because we
have some shorthand notations for the
processes so we could we could figure
out but the the point is that you need
to specify the domain right so only the
the first inputs you know the second one
it's just you know that's not enough
information so we could figure out some
kind of a line at why isn't the second
one enough information I don't know
what's the domain I mean what okay fine
if you was in that case you assume
you're gonna infer that that's fine yes
right I mean you know it might be the
case that you want to be able to say
that might have been a D there you know
in which case you need to do all the Phi
it in which case you need to qualify
like in the first right in this case but
so what do you do with random processes
for estimated distribution process and
then say number which is kind of
expanded to the understood as the order
of that but it's a special input let me
see
you mean estimator process estimated
process yes sorry Earth different thing
it's a different thing but I'm talking
about
alight it's you know form and
it's probably specified on each process
page separately because that doesn't
work for any process it works only for
the time serious processes so if you go
to a are in a sense this is very weird
what's happening here I mean because
these variables a b c v they could just
as well be blanks here those those
actual names are irrelevant unless you
call find process parameters then you
want to have the names and also you can
have repeated parameters that may ask a
be a and then it's gonna feed the
process when the parameters are the same
on the first and the third
i mean if we had a pattern we could do
that as well it could be a blank a blank
I mean can you make it can I say a B a
plus B here or does that not yes it
should work unless it's not plausible
okay so then I go here I say a plus B
now your V is specified so maybe we
should clear you know to cure disease
what doesn't matter I got a reasonable
answer yes and the thing is that right
now you got the process again with you
know of order free but if you would call
find process parameters you would only
get the least of a B and V writer so I
don't know blank process parameters on
what saintliness for but to set a
different name estimated process will
find process parameters
okay I understand that but the other
case where the names of the variables
are irrelevant do I still have to give
them even though they're irrelevant or
is there an alighted former I don't have
to give them right so you should try to
put a r-process brackets for three oh
well like that without the V without
devine does that mean something
generally and this doesn't work we've
defined process parameters because you
didn't give it the parameters so this
has to work there's only worse we've
estimated but is a our process of three
something would normally be meaningful
yeah that's usually what people say that
they talk about em a to process a I mean
I know that but I mean for us that's
something which even independent of the
variables is meaningful it's it's a
class of processes it's a family of
processes okay it's a space I understand
you often call a model structure and
it's it's so it's a set of possible
processes but it might in some case may
be a our process one argument who could
mean something else writes you are some
distribution there's a variable number
of arguments well we're making it there
assume is lost don't they require a
vector
okay but this thing a our process of
three in and of itself it's just a
symbolic shorthand for this family of a
are processes with different actual
innards in them correct yes and the
other way of specifying it with a bunch
of parameters like that is an equivalent
way of specifying that family well I
know with the ABC I hate that because
it's got very you know arbitrary names
that aren't scoped and so on as we just
saw with that V having already having a
value because you may want to estimate
something with fixed value already thank
you so you may want to that's that's
fine do I mean the way of doing that but
I would have expected it some pattern
type thing given that it doesn't care
what the values are let them be blanks
does that work no well I would argue
that that should work but I mean okay
okay so back to this estimated
distribution for and the question of
whether fine distribution could
perfectly well do this in which case
fine distribution in this case would
just do the right thing you wouldn't
need a separate estimated distribution
that's a different syntax but it's nice
also a little bit lower level we can
specify the domain and so on I agree I
it seems oh I don't know I mean this
doesn't seem right to go in and seems
very hacky to go and I mean I'm not
happy with um
not thrilled about that
not a big enthusiast of these okay so
this is very weird I mean I was another
case in the system where you have
variables here that are whose that are
actually meaningless but no variables no
they're not meaningless they I mean yes
you could have done it with patterns
here but then fine process parameters
wouldn't don't work right this is a way
of telling you where are they okay
instead of n I realize that yeah I
realize but you don't need another list
because that is itself that I don't know
okay yep because you have only a limited
set of containers so I'm not doing
estimated distribution of alpha times
gamma distribution of alpha beta no it's
only a set of known containers that's
right this is so that's for parametric
distributions so there are things that
have parameters I understand but so the
way we could think about this is you
know it's where are other cases where
you're essentially filling in you using
a function to hold a structure and then
you are filling in um okay um the it's
actually pretty good design I mean this
is Swedish design estimated distribution
of just indicating exactly what it is in
the distribution you want to estimate
you can fill in constants for the things
you don't want to estimate and you feel
you can have dependencies there which is
almost going overboard in complexity
yeah it's a pride okay okay let's keep
going here
um so I'm not buying into this
particular thing right now I mean it
well you say this one seems fine this
one is right in line with what's there
right now right the other one would be a
convenience and it could be documented
on the page for categorical distribution
of convenience
Brian Turner the other way that is allow
symbolic parameters right after because
it's similar to this is that at first I
was you know following my kind of
machining background only allowing
numeric distribution but then I realize
we can actually accept also a finale
with symbols and well it seems to be
working all right of course on a very
it's not gonna work
just a and evaluated but you know yeah I
think this is great so see any reason
not to do this okay so I'm just just
making sure that I really understand so
the basic point is the domain is
specified by if there's a if it's a
Ector thing its domain cross domain
basically yes
each dimension of the domain so how does
that relate to how wait so that's fairly
a distributions yeah it's it's it's it's
similar but that's a very effective way
to do it because instead of getting sort
of N squared you get n plus n sure and
you know and it improves with dimension
similarly yeah and by the way I assume
expectations will also work with
symbolic stuff right yeah so that I
wanted to bring that up expectations
can't really work per se for these
random variables because how are you
gonna integrate the string a and B over
the space of string a B and C so Nanako
for some reminder there's no plus
defined between the string a and b and c
hider it depends a function you put an
expectation exactly so there you have to
put in a function that in turn is
quantitative yeah like a pendulum or
something I mean yeah something that is
numeric and quantitative that now can be
summed so it's not defined on the raw
variable it's defined on functions of
the variable
yeah I agree but did you had an example
up here of what of an expectation where
you were looking at why was it you just
passed it's no lol scrolling so badly
bit I don't know where that's this build
marriage they did some tests for
front-end another after for reading
expectation yeah okay yeah write
probability that X is equal to a that
the
probability of a boolean the only
absolute probability is fine there right
yes except you can't use less than
because that is not defined for the
strings exactly but you can use equal
and unequal did you also somewhat again
be playing
diosa medicine oh yeah yeah the only
quality work as well
so X not equal to a should work yeah
yeah yeah and I assume you took care of
the I mean in let me do this
anything anything basically that because
Ferrari should work why is that one why
is that correct I guess a is because X
is always a be CEO and y is always DRI
so oh yeah right so if I say if I say a
here then we should very beautifully
Hackett yeah we enough it's cuz that's
beautiful that's beautiful
very nice you should have an example
with that because that's really nice and
I assume that you've got um well if I
had three of them x equals y equals
equals Z or something
so you've that you've dealt with I mean
it's just it's just replacing and then
evaluating it this yeah um a little bit
asking does it work with missings
what does it do with missings no does
not so you have to fully specify the
distribution yeah the whole world of
missing the calculus of missing will
have to come later them I work in in the
estimated distribution does amazing
thing right not not for defining free
distribution can be missing data but not
missing models okay so you're using a
data set which can nest arbitrarily so
that's all yeah and as you see I didn't
reevaluate it in this bill so you could
try to see what it gives with this new
data set
I'm curious very much the Schneider
looks fine and when it gets really big
okay that's an example good check if you
evaluate that when it gets big get the
top probabilities kind of switch to top
probabilities nice same for information
and the last thing but definitely think
that we need to talk is this all the
creation okay well they're not the
product distribution what what's what's
for that now Pro distribution that's
something that it's working for
univariate for multivariate think we see
their problems that's something which
goes yeah we have to figure out okay how
can make that work okay no you passed it
you passed it just full of creation on
time doing this with my um that's : ok
ok ok recall distribution like that's
all the way which yeah to my taste
there's a bit too many way to create a
regular distribution that's why I was a
bit against when you're you know
repeating elements to take the
statistics because it's yet another way
to create the distribution but anyway
discuss about that so this we already
saw you know now okay
that's the domain dress array rules
which I think
pretty nice in the material case yeah I
agree with you
[Music]
and it would follow it would fall over
like sponsor a type thing that if you
put a blank and that could be an
association as well it could be an
association Holloway its work with with
random choice we have both an
association form and a and a list form
for that yes it is the other way in
random choice its weight board actually
I don't know on documentation I just saw
the no random choice I think it gives
you and only if you can thread the you
know yes you have a real is to least and
if you can't thread it at least it's not
documented those red is not documented
why don't you check I doubt you can
because I think it's trying to pick
between and it's thinking you're picking
between yeah it doesn't work it doesn't
work so excellent this list of rule
doesn't work in random tries on the
random choice has this weights arrow
whatever thing yep which I didn't kept
because then with too many rules and I
followed what was in weighted data
instead okay that case there's a place
where you're implicitly defining the
domain yes yes yes
which for the multivariate is not great
because you always miss something in
domain that is always I mean actually
well you have to you have to puff out to
the domain just by looking at everything
that occurred in the first element
everything we couldn't second element
domain like that exactly actually
actually actually in most cases I think
is gonna be fine it's gonna be
especially using the univariate I
believe okay look if you're doing it
like this
it seems to me you can't get away from
the repeated you know a a B or something
without the weights there
having some being something that treats
it as weighted so I can do that I mean
it's it's a reasonable but this is
clearly useful I mean the main thing
that I wonder is what is the canonical
form and if I say you know if I want to
get out okay let's say I want to get out
that result of the list of what I do I
get out this thing here you can look at
information
I mean reevaluate things I'm not sure
its value and if you do information look
at the properties I think it's just
going to be probabilities but let's
check let's check all the so you have
probably know that probability
probability array will just give the
array one to four means the what's going
on Oh on the information yeah you can
put city here okay so that's an
association I say Shan you can check in
the multivariate it's going to be an
association as well so by the way this
follows what in a classifier function
when you do probabilities it's also an
association that's why it like this in
the multivariate it's going to be also
an association which is basically
probability grows weaker probity
function on us because it can return
well that's weird
but it does that rather than a direct
product thing that it does the nested
associations there yeah and the good
thing that you can use it as a function
here you can put ad if you want and that
asset will will work which is nice which
also requires a bit of less repetition
of the show but both will be useful and
I don't even know how you get between
them as intruders there's an association
transpose e type thing that gets you
between those two things
yeah top probabilities would give you
this
so I guess top probabilities arrow all
could give you exactly that but it would
be so low I didn't yeah yeah I mean
that's kind of a blah if I might say so
that that gives you something which is a
very different form from probabilities
yeah yeah it kind of follows what we had
yeah
plus fear function which does classifier
function probably stop probabilities
would kind of give you that actually
just follow yeah my concern here is that
this this is clearly useful form but so
is the flattened version so is this the
anomalous this version right the
question how do we refer to those two
things I mean we
call it probability data set and return
this as a data set that's what probably
table does okay yeah there's a lot of
yeah naming to do for different things
that have similar names yeah I could
have the fat version
we find with that I don't see the value
of having in addition to this
probability table yeah okay okay um
flatten things out yeah I think so
and probability table then becomes the
the nested creature and for the
univariate case they're all the same
anyway now why is this a list rather
than Association I think that should be
an association this this I cannot
disagree because it's like there's some
missing things you know it's like I feel
it's not a fixed set and that's already
what we have in class with your function
if you top probabilities it is a list I
don't know in the in the spirits it's
like I cannot use it as a function you
know to query something programmatically
because I don't know what's gonna come
up that point so I prefer that okay we
should wrap up April I think we've
pretty much finished
so there's ya know let's talk let's talk
about it during our ml meeting
amia it's a tiny thing so anything that
they're like new things about there some
new features about labeling the
anomalies formal detection functions
that it's like following the classified
um we have a couple of comments on our
livestream before we wrap up here
Mohammed is asking does there always
exists a copula distribution that
connects any set of marginals to the
corresponding Joint Distribution I do
not know the answer to that don't know
either there can be more kernels than
the ones that we support right nice l
function fine cultural kernel that finds
what copula kernel dependency structure
exists for any Joint Distribution this
strikes me as being very similar to you
know the whole direction with I don't
know graphical models and all these
various interdependency ways
representing yeah yeah it's it's it's
somewhat along those lines the the
graphical stuff it's basically only sold
for two cases
I don't normal categorical they don't go
outside of that they keep it to the
stuff where you can actually can compute
relatively straightforward fair enough
it's really useful for us to have but um
yeah yeah yeah no no there's nothing
against that but I'm saying copula is
richer when it comes to dependency
structure right much much richer South
is asking because they may transform the
categorical distribution would be
susceptible to an expectation operator
sorry I think I think we have I think we
covered that they and South Azaz game
could classifier measurements could have
a categorical distribution as one of its
properties in addition to confusion
function then directly take random
variates of that distribution do you
understand that at him I think I missed
something in the middle supplier
measurements you know in addition to
confusion function which I don't know
that's one of the confusion oh yeah yeah
it's like confusion metrics but then you
can query the two classes and right
instead of returning a confusion
function you just return a foe
distribution yeah represents what's in
that that is interesting I mean that's
analogous to what um like you know the
Census Bureau wants to do where you get
a thing that you can query to find
properties of you know of random
Americans so to speak even without
having any actual Americans in there so
to speak if that makes yeah yeah yeah
then you could compute expectation or
whatever things like that that we useful
to return then maybe yeah okay something
to think about okay all right I gotta go
to something completely different
um this is great very nice any any
further
another thing else we should cover here
sounds great okay let's hopefully we'll
see a documentation page
soon but I'm sure it can go through the
Roger process and and yeah should be
good and don't forget I mean I I just
feel like this should be um piecewise
somehow relates I don't know maybe it's
not related I don't know I just see also
between those might be useful hmm um all
right great thanks all thanks to folks
on the livestream to see you soon all
right